ANGER ON THE STREETS OF CHINESE CITIES
THE BIGGEST BIGGEST NATIONWIDE
DISPLAY THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN A
GENERATION --
PROTESTERS, PUSHING BACK
AGAINST POLICE AND THE
GOVERNMENT'S ZERO COVID POLICY.
THE UNREST TRIGGERED BY A
DEADLY FIRE IN A, RISHI IN
CHINA'S WESTERN XINJIANG REGION
LAST THURSDAY.
VIDEOS EMERGED OF FIRE HOSES,
BARELY REACHING THE BLAZE WHICH
KILLED AT LEAST TEN PEOPLE.
AMONG, THEN A WOMAN AND FOUR OF
HER CHILDREN.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO YOUR MOTHER
AND YOUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS?
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> TRANSLATOR: THE FIRE STARTED
IN THE 15TH FLOOR.
THE SMOKE POISON MY FAMILY, THE
GOVERNMENT CANNOT STOP THE FIRE
IN TIME.
TWO SURVIVING ADULT SPEAK TO ME
FROM TURKEY, UNABLE TO SEE
THEIR FAMILY SINCE 2017 DUE TO
THE HARSH CRACKDOWN.
THE GOVERNMENT ACCUSED OF
PUTTING UP 2 MILLION OF THEIR
FELLOW ETHNIC LEADERS AND
MEMBERS OF OTHER MINORITIES IN
INTERNMENT CAMPS.
THEY SAY THAT THEIR LOVED ONES
WERE TRAPPED IN THE BUILDING BY
COVID MEASURES.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> TRANSLATOR: WE CANNOT ESCAPE
BECAUSE THE FIRE ESCAPE WAS
BLOCKED, AND THE FIRE-SCAPE TO
THE NEW BUILDING WAS ALSO
LOCKED.
>> ACCUSATION CNN CANNOT
INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM, BUT
CHINESE AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN
SEEN LITERALLY, LOCKING
RESIDENTS INTO BUILDINGS.
>> OUTRAGED OVER THE RICHIE
FIRE COMPOUNDED BY PREVIOUS
DEADLY INCIDENTS IN RECENT
MONTHS, DIRECTLY LINKED TO
COVID PREVENTION'S.
THE, CNN VERIFIED 16 PROTESTS
IN 11 CHINESE CITIES, THIS
WEEKEND, A CHINESE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL TOLD THE JOURNALIST
THEY JUST DIDN'T HAPPEN.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> TRANSLATOR: WHAT HE
MENTIONED DOES NOT REFLECT WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
CHINA HAS BEEN FOLLOWING THE
DYNAMIC ZERO COVID POLICY.
THAT HAS BEEN MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS BASED ON REALITY ON
THE GROUND.
>> ON MONDAY, THE WHITE PAPERS
THAT HAVE BECOME A SYMBOL OF
THE PROTESTS IN MAINLAND CHINA
SPREAD HERE TO HONG KONG WHERE
THE SMALL GROUPS OF
DEMONSTRATORS ARE HOLDING A
VIGIL FOR WHAT THEY SAY ARE THE
VICTIMS OF CHINA'S ZERO COVID
POLICY.
>> I AM A VICTIM.
>> I CANNOT GO HOME FOR MANY
YEARS LIKE 2 TO 3 YEARS, RIGHT?
>> MY PARENTS WERE LOCKED DOWN
FOR THREE MONTHS.
EVEN RELATIVES OF MY GOOD
FRIENDS THEY SUICIDE BECAUSE OF
THE LOCKDOWN.
>> WITH CHINA REPORTING RECORD
BREAKING NEW DAILY CASES OF
COVID, THERE APPEARS TO BE NO
END TO THE LOCKDOWNS INSIDE.
MEANWHILE, SIBLINGS MOHAMMED
AND --
, CANNOT EVEN PRAY FOR CLOSURE
AFTER SUFFERING THE
UNIMAGINABLE LOSS OF FIVE
IMMEDIATE MEMBERS OF THEIR
FAMILY.
>> WILL YOU GO HOME FOR THE
FUNERAL OF YOUR FAMILY?
>> WE WANT TO ATTEND THE
FUNERAL OF OUR FAMILY MEMBERS
BUT IF WE WENT BACK NOW, CHINA
WILL PUT US IN JAIL OR EVEN
TORTURE US.
IVAN WATSON,
>> SUCH A HEARTBREAKING STORY
THERE.
AND LIKE IVAN JUST SAID, THESE
PROTESTS HAVE BEEN HAPPENING
AMID NEW RECORD COVID
INFECTIONS IN CHINA OVER THE
PAST FEW DAYS.
THIS DESPITE LOCKDOWNS AND
MANDATORY MASS TESTING.
ON MONDAY, CHINA REPORTING MORE
THAN 38,000 CASES.
NOW, THE NUMBER, WHILE IT IS OF
COURSE HIGH FOR CHINA.
IT BREAKS THE STREAK OF SIX
CONSECUTIVE DAYS OF RECORD
HIGHS.
JOINING ME NOW IS DR.
RODRIGUEZ.
A BOARD CERTIFIED IN INTERNAL
MEDICINE SPECIALIST AND VIRAL
RESEARCHER.
JOINS ME NOW FROM LOS ANGELES.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
AND I WISH WE WERE NOT SPEAKING
ABOUT SUCH A VULNERABLE PART OF
THE WORLD.
STILL SO VULNERABLE TO THIS
VIRUS.
YOU, KNOW I HAVE TO, SAY IT
SEEMS LIKE FOR CHINA, TIME HAS
STOOD STILL HERE.
RIGHT?
WHAT OPTIONS DOES IT HAVE?
ESPECIALLY GIVEN HOW VULNERABLE
ITS POPULATION IS.
WITH LACK OF VACCINES.
>> I THINK YOU MAKE A GREAT
POINT.
CHINA, THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE
TIME STAND STILL.
CHINA'S MOVING FORWARD.
THE VIRUSES MOVING FORWARD.
SO, THEY DO NOT HAVE MANY
OPTIONS.
BECAUSE CHINA HAS RELIED ON
JUST THIS VERY TO TELL A
THERRIEN TYPE OF BLOCKADE IF
YOU WILL.
THE VIRUS HAS CHANGED.
OMICRON CHANGED THE WHOLE THING
BY BECOMING SO RESISTANT.
UNFORTUNATELY, CHINA DOES NOT
HAVE A GOOD PLAN B.
THEY DO NOT HAVE A GOOD VACCINE.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING MANDATORY, THEY
SHOULD HAVE THEIR PEOPLE HAVE A
MANDATORY VACCINE.
SO I THINK THAT THIS HORSE THIS
OUT OF THE BARN.
THE FACT THEY ARE HAVING THIS
MANY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
INFECTIONS NOW.
IT MEANS THAT THE ZERO
TOLERANCE, THE ZERO
AVAILABILITY OF PEOPLE TO GET
OUT OF THEIR HOMES IS ALREADY A
VERY FAILED TACTIC.
>> YEAH, WHAT DO THEY DO NOW?
DOCTOR ANTHONY FAUCI WAS ON CNN
MONDAY.
HE OFFERED HIS THOUGHTS AND WAS
QUITE CANDID ABOUT THE ACT AS A
SCIENTIST, IT WAS HARD TO KEEP
ONE STEP AHEAD OF THIS VIRUS.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN OUT ABOUT
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THE CHINESE
SITUATION.
>> WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
SHUTTING THINGS DOWN, IT SHOULD
ALWAYS BE A TEMPORARY
PHENOMENON.
NOT A LONG RANGE STRATEGY.
BUT YOU SHOULD DO IT WITH A
PURPOSE IN MIND.
TO ALLOW YOU TO OPEN.
>> IN TERMS OF ALLOWING TO OPEN,
WHAT CAN CHINA DO EVEN IF THEY
WANTED TO PULL BACK A LITTLE
BIT FROM THE COVID ZERO POLICY?
GIVEN THE FACT THAT VACCINATION
LIVES ARE SO LOW.
>> THAT IS WHY I THINK THEY ARE
BETWEEN A ROCK AND A HARD
PLACE.
THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE.
THAT THEY NEED TO BRING IN GOOD
VACCINES TO THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
POPULOUS COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO.
I THINK PART OF THE REASON WHY
THEY ARE RESORTING TO THESE
ZERO COVID POLICIES IS BECAUSE
THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
FINANCIAL MEANS TO BRING REALLY
GOOD VACCINES.
SO, I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
BE WITH A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
BECAUSE THE FACT THEY ARE
ALREADY HAVING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CASES PER DAY.
THESE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY.
SO I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO
THAT, BUT I THINK THEY MIGHT
HAVE TO REACH OUT
DIPLOMATICALLY AND TRY TO SEEK
HELP FROM THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
THAT DO HAVE MRNA VACCINES AND
DO HAVE BETTER WAYS OF
PROTECTING THEIR PEOPLE.
>> THE REST OF THE WORLD HAS
ALREADY SAID IT IS THERE TO
HELP IF CHINA ASK SORT.
IT HAS NOT SO.
FAR I WANT TO GO THROUGH WHAT
WAS REALLY A CHILLING
ASSESSMENT EARLIER THIS YEAR.
IT WAS PUBLISHED IN NATURE
MEDICINE IN MAY.
IT WAS REALLY TRYING TO SPELL
OUT WHAT AN OMICRON WAVE WOULD
MEAN FOR CHINA.
AND THIS IS JUST THE CONCLUSION
AFTER A LOT OF RESEARCH.
WE FIND THAT THE LEVEL OF
IMMUNITY INDUCED BY THE MARCH
2022 VACCINATION CAMPAIGN WOULD
BE INSUFFICIENT TO PREVENT AND
OMICRON WAVE THAT WOULD RESULT
IN EXCEEDING CRITICAL CARE
CAPACITY.
LET US UNDERSCORE.
THAT EXCEEDING CRITICAL CARE
CAPACITY WITH THE PROJECTED
PEAK OF 15.6 TIMES THE EXISTING
CAPACITY.
AND CAUSING APPROXIMATELY 1.5
MILLION DEATHS.
DOCTOR, WHERE DO YOU GO FROM
THAT KIND OF STAT.
VACCINATION RATES HAVE NOT
MOVED THAT MUCH.
HOW ALARMING IS THAT?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR 1.4 BILLION
PEOPLE.
>> IT'S VERY ALARMING.
NOT JUST FOR THOSE 1.4 BILLION
PEOPLE, BUT THE FACT YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE 1.4 BILLION
PEOPLE THAT EVEN A SMALL
FRACTION OF THAT ARE GOING TO
BE RE-PRODUCING NEW VIRUSES AND
WILL AFFECT THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
THEY WILL TEST TO WAKE UP TO
THE FACT THAT MAYBE THE WAY
CHINA GOES WITH A NEW WAVE IN
INFECTIONS, IS THE WAY THE
WORLD MIGHT GO.
SO REALLY, THIS IS GOING TO
NEED TO BE A CONCERTED EFFORT.
IF CHINA IS GOING TO USE
TOTALITARIAN TACTICS TO TRY TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF COVID,
THEY SHOULD USE AND I AM NOT
ADVOCATING TO TELL A TRAIN,
ANYTHING DON'T GET ME WRONG.
THEY SHOULD USE AT LEAST
SOMETHING THAT WORKS.
AND THE ONLY THING THAT IS
WORKING NOW TO SOME DEGREE, TO
DECREASE THE SPREAD, TO THE
DEATHS IS MRNA VACCINES, THAT
IS WHERE I THINK THEY NEED TO
HEAD.
THEY NEED TO SEEK HELP FROM THE
REST OF THE WORLD, THEY NEED TO
HUMBLE THEMSELVES AND SEEK
EXTERNAL HELP.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT IS
UNLIKELY THEY WILL DO THAT.
I WANT TO DRILL DOWN ON THE
CONSEQUENCES YOU ARE JUST
TALKING ABOUT.
1.4 BILLION PEOPLE, IF COVID
DOESN'T GET TO A POINT WHERE IT
IS UNCONTROLLABLE THERE, THERE
ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD.
IN TERMS OF THE WAY VIRUSES
BEHAVE RIGHT?
>> OF COURSE.
THAT IS MY WHOLE POINT, LISTEN,
WE ARE NOT ISOLATED.
THAT IS WHY FROM THE BEGINNING,
THIS WAY OF TREATING COVID WAS
DOOMED.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO CONCERTED
EFFORT WITH THE WHOLE WORLD.
YOU CAN'T JUST TREATED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
UK.
COMPLETELY UNITED BY
TRANSPORTATION, BY IMMIGRATION.
BY ECONOMICS.
THAT IS WHAT HAS BEEN LACKING.
IN MAYBE THE W.H.O. DID NOT DO
ENOUGH, BUT WE CAN'T JUST BLAME
ON THE W.H.O..
IF EVERY COUNTRY IS NOT GOING
TO COOPERATE, REALIZE WE ARE
ALL IN THIS TOGETHER, WE ARE
GOING TO BE WHERE WE ARE.
FORTUNATELY, I THINK WE ARE TOO
LACKADAISICAL THESE DAYS.
TAKING IT FOR GRANTED.
PEOPLE ARE NOT DYING AS MUCH.
SO WHAT'S NEXT?
THE SUPER VIRUS THAT IS GOING
TO COMPLETELY OBLITERATED A
GREAT PORTION OF THE WORLD?
IT MIGHT HAPPEN.
AND CHINA IS A 1.4 TRILLION
PETRI DISH POSSIBILITY.
>> CHILLING WHEN YOU PUT IT IN
THOSE TERMS.
AGAIN, THE UNFINISHED BUSINESS
OF THIS PANDEMIC.
DR. RODRIGUEZ, THANK YOU AGAIN.